[Music]
your money's not here it's on the
blockchain it's in Joe's transaction and
mrs. Malins transaction it's a digital
currency run down to the marketed by the
biggest turkey and all of London then
take it to Bob Cratchit's house do it
faster this have a crowded it for you
well is that it I'm sorry that's your
contribution to society huh half a crown
in a turkey I also donate to charity
oh great charity where you get to decide
where your money goes yes Wow
yes after I pay federal and state and
local taxes the remaining money I
dictate what it goes that is so like the
1% it's people like you who are
destroying America Britain or wherever
the hell we are you donate money to
charity surgeries awareness on Facebook
that doesn't sound like a real thing
it's a real thing why don't you do that
and volunteer at a soup kitchen of time
to volunteer because I'm raising
awareness on Facebook and when the ship
and saw the light in the sky they
rejoiced with exceeding great joy for
the space X Falcon 9 rocket had
successfully launched the satellite into
orbit and returned autonomously to their
platform
[Music]
we need these tariffs our trade deficit
with the North Pole has never been
bigger santa is killing us on trade
he's killing there's there's a trade
deficit between me and the grocery store
that doesn't mean I need to have more
taxes on me buying groceries his carol
singers
[Music]
and paste him in a manger because there
was no room at the end for the City
Council hit band Airbnb has
anti-competitive all these people are
talking about Santa's naughty list and
is nice list but it's his kill list that
should concern us
[Music]
you've got a foreigner violating DC
airspace and you're telling me we don't
need a wall listen kiddo you're getting
older and it's time we had a talk
there's no such thing as Sanders the man
Israel but the policies are just fantasy
it's something that we made up so that
kids and college sophomores would have
something to get excited about
you selfish undemocratic prick I don't
understand what you want from me you
have too much stuff give us your stuff
the system which incentivizes me to
accumulate stuff also it's it advises me
to create wealth for you oh well then
why are there poor people object poverty
is the natural state of man the question
isn't why they're to pull people it's
why that it rich me posteriors stuff no
yeah I am so gonna pick at this house
good luck you wonder a restaurant buddy
we're gonna be there
[Music]
you